[Music]
don't be a fake
don't be a flake don't run away from
your feelings babe don't be afraid don't
be ashamed don't hesitate to say
hey babe hey babe hey babe
hey
share subscribe her and like her
through the night with the light from
above
hey babe hey babe how are you doing i'm
doing good happy fourth happy fourth of
july
for me nothing says fourth of july like
a vancouver grizzlies sweatshirt that's
right that's what it is was that a teal
that's a teal what do you think about
that you know what teal no matter who
you are it stops you in your tracks
you think so because teal is so such a
such bold choice why don't we go teal
for our team colors then why don't we
why don't we do teens
who's i mean well the grizzlies well and
who else is it the tampa no the tampa
bay right now the raison the tampa bay
shout out to the tampa bay bucks yeah
got it
but i just want to shout them out the
tampa bay buccaneers won the super bowl
congrats tom brady uh
pulled it off it was it was it's insane
insanity patrick mahomes
of course you can't say enough about
that kansas city chiefs
um god bless yeah let me ask you a
question now
sure i mean a grizzly bear a grizzly
bear
it's i think it's probably the best
mascot
ever who's beating the grizzle who's
being a raptor
r the toronto we're talking about
fierceness and
and alphaness yeah like i think a raptor
beats a grizzly probably right it's
interesting the canadian sports teams
because you got the vancouver grizzlies
which are not a team anymore than the
toronto raptors and they're gonna have
the toronto blue jays
yeah which is a real drop-off tweet
tweet tweet tweet
yeah i know yeah it's a real drop-off
blue jay people watch them in silence
through binocs yeah
it's not threatening at all not like
you're going into a game in silence just
watching the players through binoculars
a grizzly and a raptor though
forget about it you have a good bird
watching never been bird watching in my
life
has it ever piqued your interest have
you ever even thought of it do you
understand why people do it
i went to the zoo once and went to the
bird sanctuary
and couldn't believe that i paid to
stand real drag
i mean it was even my daughter was just
like dad let's get to the i mean let's
see the penguins
let's see the gorillas well penguin is
like a bird watch
is it penguin a bird no way a penguin
can't be a bird penguin is a bird dude
isn't a penguin a bird penguin's not
foul
let me ask you this question are fish
penguins are fish mammals or amphibians
because they live in water orlando both
penguins are birds which one is it
are they beautiful birds i don't
understand
no but i don't think what did you click
on here is this some some he said is
penguin a bird that's what
janky penguins are birds even though
they spend
i think they just identify as what they
feel how about this you ready for this
you ready for this babe i don't know if
i am
penguins native to anor two i'm gonna
get to it penguins are native to
antarctica i have a wild
i i need to talk to you about antarctica
and what i've discovered i was watching
docks on antarctica all night last night
but real quick before i do that
if i gave you the opportunity you have
to eat one would you eat
would you eat a penguin sandwich or a
panda sandwich ah
jesus christ you have to eat one ah what
is it like an exotic uh buffet
it's exotic buffet night on tgi fridays
well i will say like penguin if it is a
bird
poultry i'm kind of in that i've been in
that family already i've tasted chicken
and
okay and and that kind of stuff so i i
guess a penguin now the penguin
community don't come after me
right you know i've i'm putting in front
of me an option and i have to choose one
last thing you need is danny devito
coming after you yeah exactly
panda meat i don't know panda meat's got
to be you people probably have had
meat too right i think people have eaten
panda i think i want to say pant
humans apparently ate panda in
prehistoric times oh i thought you
you said panda and the whole time in my
head i was thinking panther
panther panther no i'm talking about
panda
oh i wouldn't want to eat panda meat i
would chop i would stop that penguin up
with a biscuit
prehistoric contemporary chinese have
little taste for the animal panda
banquets are unheard of
they're certainly too precious to eat
but their flavor might also have kept
them off the dinner table
they don't taste good they don't taste
good i thought a panda would taste good
to be honest
it looks like it might what about hello
panda the uh the chocolate cookies you
ever have those
absolutely not never even heard of them
yeah dude i thought hello panda was like
an
asian fast food no hello panda cookie
panda express the asians are big with
the hellos hello panda hello kitty
yeah panda express they're happy people
pan hello pandas hello kitty meets panda
express
that's what it is it really is how about
hello panda express
panda express that serves the cookies
all right go to chrisdcomedy.com for
stand-up tickets i'm coming all over
i got providence rhode island eatontown
new jersey philadelphia pennsylvania
nashville tennessee
and the fox theater at foxwoods
connecticut newark new jersey
seattle portland christy comedy.com more
shows coming i'm bringing tt if she's
allowed to leave the state
you know that hello kitty i think is
like one of the most
like profitable companies of all time
sanyo i think it's called
i would imagine sanrio i would imagine
that guy yeah i mean that thing
think about this whenever that came out
it still is prominent and relevant today
hello kitty hello
kids walk around with the backpacks and
according to the legend hello kitty was
created back in the 70s by a chinese
woman apparently her 14 year old
daughter
was diagnosed with cancer of the mouth
the doctors told the mother that her
child was terminally ill and there was
nothing they could do for her
what kind of article is that well did
she make it i mean what is it
that's the article did she make it
i also heard hello kitty is uh not to
get all like
but i heard she i think she's not
even a female she's a cat she's a cat
oh as a young female a
japanese bobtail cat i heard someone say
that she's neither male nor female
or they that she's she's fluid
she's a cat oh yeah like they won't
assign there we go
why is hello kitty not a cat hello
kitty's uh oh that's it she's not a cat
she's a girl
that's it she's a cartoon character she
is a little girl though this article is
that's what it was that's what it's like
she's not a cat but she's a cat
but she to me it's like i would say
hello kitty's a cat but if my daughter
asked me
is hello kitty a boy or girl i'd say
it's a girl yes i say it's a little girl
cat
as i would too yes yeah some stories go
hello kitty was designed with no mouth
because the daughter had had mouth
cancer kitty's pointed ears represent
satan's horns
kitty in chinese means demon oh god so
hello kitty is hello demon
so do you think the asians are just like
look at them like do you think that it's
just all on purpose i think that's a q
anon theory
speaking of q anon let me talk about
antarctica let me talk about antarctica
before i talk about it though i just
want to shout out christy comedy.com i
got stand up dates coming up
all over we might put a show up on sale
in antarctica after i tell you the story
because i got to go there
but we do have uh the the fox theater
october 23rd um in connecticut we've
added a show please go get those tickets
uh eatontown new jersey almost sold out
lovely town we just opened up tickets
for this listen to this july 22
24th providence rhode island it was sold
out forever but now they open up tickets
thank you the governor of
rhode island whoever that guy is i'm
sure he's an irishman so we got we got
added ticket sales there and then we got
nashville newark new jersey
seattle portland chrisdcomedy.com so
check it out nice babe you're all over
the
road now i'm back on the road we're back
out there and and and uh
and yeah so let me tell you about
something
antarctica i don't know nothing about it
okay well how about this
did you know did you know that it's
speculated
that german uh the nazis
during world war ii were using it as a
base
as a as a as like an underground base
to um do testing to do testing with
uh ancient alien warcrafts and alien
um civilization they believe people
believe ancient alien civilizations live
on antarctica
and the reason why there's a treaty
right now you cannot there's a national
treaty
right now amongst all the nations of the
world
love a good treaty there's a there's a
there's a a
a treaty out right now that says nobody
can do anything on antarctica no
countries are allowed to do anything
no no they only made that treaty i don't
google the antarctic treaties who makes
treaties the government
i would say the government still do
treaties they still do traditionally
treat his an old thing
no like right now i don't remember the
last time i saw like one of our current
day politicians be like i'm gonna do a
treaty they just did the well that like
the green peace deal the new green
was that a tree it's a treaty but
they're calling it a deal now maybe
maybe what the i like the name treaty i
like truth sounds like it sounds like
it's
it's a treat you know like it's true
they got cute with it yeah like how are
we going to get people how are we going
to pass this
let's go i'm going to pass this bill
golden tree gold treaty give him a
little treaty yeah a little treaty for
you we
yeah who wants to sign the treaty
[Laughter]
so but google antarctica treaty so i
want to make sure i
the anarchy treaty was signed uh
december 1st 1959 by the 12 countries
whose scientists
had been active in and around antarctica
which by the way i've called it my whole
life antarctica it's antarctica i'd be
like oh antarctica i noticed today since
you arrived here we were downstairs when
you said antarctica earlier you said it
like that and i was like oh that's very
because when i'm watching the
documentary i said what a fool like an
arctic
i've been saying antarctica so have i i
mean
but it's antarctica because the last
thing you want to do is be disrespectful
on 4th of july i'm not going to
disrespect antarctica antarctica
antarctica okay antarctica um antarctica
the antarctic treaty it's basically um
military activity is banned as is
prospecting for minerals and a lot of
people believe
that the reason why it's banned is
because the countries of the world
you know this treaty there's ancient
civilization that used to live there
people think the the lost city of
atlantis used to be there
people think it was for sure as near as
12 000 years ago
not covered in ice and a full
civilization lived there and then the
polls change the north pole became the
south pole
and they did a switch route and then it
got covered in ice like almost
immediately
the old pole switcheroo which allegedly
is the thing that happens though the
poles just switch
and that um victor schauenberg who was a
nazi scientist was then taken in this
thing called operation
paperclip by the united states the
united states took all the german nazi
scientists that were making all the
technology
stuff this guy schauenberger they took
him
and the u.s took him and they put him on
an arts and he was making he's making
all like the ufo sightings that we're
having today
are really reverse engineering aircrafts
from this antarctic time
in world war ii we've had the technology
for 70 years it's all just been locked
away in antarctica and now they've
escaped from antarctica and are flying
over regions of southern california and
the nevada
this has been hey babe
what if we did that we put out an
eight-minute episode
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah oh how we just left left had a good
time you thought it was over
you thought it was over oh and there's
pyramids on antarctica
scientists think there's pyramids they
think the ancient not the egyptians
another alien civilization
built the pyramids on aeronautica i was
watching this stuff all night it's so
much more than penguins
can i ask you a question about
antioxidants yes this might
sound a little green yes uh like my
shirt
yes um do people go to antarctica
yes is there a uh residential
big high there and then go to the town
square big hot topic right now
is should tourism be allowed in
antarctica and the answer right now is
yes so if we're going to go to
antarctica we have a window but it's
small here's what we got to do
we got to fly to chile we fly you fly to
chile and then you fly to the most
southern part of chile a town i think
it's called uzuku or something like that
and then you take a boat 600 miles
why do you know this bro i'm telling you
i'm telling you it's so you you give me
specific instructions
i am in on antarctica you're antarctica
i mean i'm antarctica okay okay so you
go to chile you take a boat you fly to
chile
isn't it fun to say chile chile because
people say chili chile
is a hundred times better than chili
chile chile
is where i go to go to antarctica
chili's is where i go if somebody
graduates in my family yeah baby back
yes
yeah somebody
antarctic hotels range from luxury
lodges to comfortable campsites
so you can go to antarctica let me ask
you a question are we going to
antarctica for the patreon yeah or not
yeah put it on the list if it's on the
list it happens
we should we should go there for like a
week and just film like
a hundred hours of content here's the
cheap here's the chief tricks to get to
antarctica nine day cruise
may not hit all the destinations in
antarctica which you really want to see
but it will be cheaper than the 23-day
long haul depending on the size of the
boats can accommodate 80 to
uh 80 to 500 peeps at a time so you get
23 days to get there if you are
a listener of ours from antarctica
please make yourself known
yes right now in the comments we will
contact you next episode
so we can ask you questions directly yes
on antarctica
residents yes 11 kids have been born in
the air
because you gotta understand argentina
and chile are so close to the equator
those southern parts
it's not it's a hop skipping to jump to
antarctica for them we what do you mean
and are you gonna be like is it
antarctica at this
at the at the southern listening with
the north pole do you believe that earth
is
do you believe the earth is round or
flat what flat flat okay so you believe
it's flat then it's an ice shield
that it's an ice wall that goes all the
way around the country like a box if you
believe it's flat
if you that's if you believe it's flat
believe it's round then it would be at
the
southern at the south pole the
southernmost so so there are no
permanent residents there what is that
what is that scientists are there
science i mean yes so nobody
so it's just scientists and like they
live in a townhouse that they built for
them and there's no one else there
nobody else there but how could that be
you can't just be on a continent
yourself no but but it's because it's
all for science mcdonald's tried to put
in a bid to
build a mcdonald's on antarctica but it
got shot down i mean
how how is that a profitable business
model there's nobody
well the scientists allegedly they oh
you know what else you could do
you can go on this ship on the ship to
cause could they take you to the
northern
most part of antarctica you know even
though it's in the south it's the
northernmost tip it's like a little
archipelago
yeah of um
archipelago archipelago archipelago
okay archipelago archipelago
i think it's archipelago i think it's
arch you want to hit me with a new tab
want to hit me with that pronunciation
yeah let's is it
a r first of all let's see i think it's
archipelago
archipelago let's see let's hear it
smash that
archipelago what do we say
did i say archipelago i know what i said
anymore i just wanted to make it sound
i wanted to make it sound a little bit i
want to spruce it up a little bit so i
said archipelago
right now mcdonald's goes there the
golden archipelagos that's the sandwich
i mean just call us so what you can do
is when you get there when you get to
antarctica
yeah and uh to the northern part of the
archipelago
arc is it archipelago what do you say
again
archipelago archipelago arc
so it's not arch it's yeah it's
archipelago so when you get to the
archipelago
yeah you can you can
jump off the boat into the water and dip
in the arctic ocean you could be one of
the only people that takes a dip and
they get you right out now you are
risking getting eaten by a humpback
whale immediately
yeah but if you dip in you get out uh
there is a
national airport there no it's just got
to be like a little bit of a little
runway
well here we go let me just some quick
fun facts commonly spoken language of
antarctica's russian which happens to be
the official language of the bellingham
zuiza
uh and oginia english is also one of the
most widespread language you've spoken
you could find english spoken in the
fellaini islands
new south greenland eduardo so the
official language is russian and
american give me an
antarctic ant art antarctic antarctica
population can i take a guess quick
please i want you that what are we here
for but i swear to god they never ever
ever
said it but i'm gonna guess their
population under 10 000.
i was going to say 800. yeah
what is population of antarctica there
we go
four thousand four ninety wow what'd you
say ten thousand ten thousand how close
you were ten thousand you won no
actually you're closer because i said
ten thousand you say eight hundred it's
it's underneath five thousand you're
closer plus i went over for
prices what do i get you get the washer
dryer combination great
yeah right which i need you should have
said i should have said one dollar
no i would have lost anyway i should
have said 801 yeah that's what i should
have i know
what what are you going to do what are
you going oh there's 12 countries in
antarctica
this there is that's what this is 12
countries in antarctica
established bases there argentina
argentina australia
belgium chile france japan new zealand
norway south africa soviet union united
kingdom and of course the united states
happy fourth of july there's a chance
you could live on antarctica
and know everyone how about this how
many people do you think you know
really how many people you think you
know like what okay let me i know of
you've exchanged words with at minimum
acquaintance
do i have to have their phone numbers in
my phone no you know i know them
you say hey bill he says hey chris i
would say i know
1500 people what do you think you know
i don't know i think more than that you
think more yeah yeah in
my lifetime cumulative yeah i don't know
it's got to be more than that but
i probably have 1500 numbers in my phone
well let me kieran
i know that because i've never erased a
number since the first time i ever got a
phone
in 1998. you've never erased a phone no
i have the numbers i entered into my
phone
in 1998 are still in my phone i do that
not because i keep cut in time with
everybody but because if someone ever
calls me from my past
right i want to know who it is it's like
a built-in caller id buffer
so if somebody calls you with an
unidentified number they
really don't know you they really don't
have really never met you because you
i don't answer somebody could call you
from 1998
yeah that you haven't spoken to since
1998 name will pop up correct
they'll say they could text you say hey
you know hey style i haven't spoken a
long time since 1988. fyi it's bill
you're all right back
i know what up bill i know it's you i
know it's you yeah i got your numbers
safe
that's amazing to have numbers in your
phone pre-911 i know i know
you got pre-911 phone numbers yeah yeah
wow yeah well
what what do you do you do a purge every
time you get a new phone i'm one of
those guys i didn't do it on purpose
you know i kind of carried over and i'm
like i'm not gonna go in there and
delete i'm one of those guys
i never like know how to upload to the
cloud or this and natural i'm one of
those guys my phone gets completely
wiped every time i break like new phone
need your numbers again the verizon guy
or whenever i get a new phone like you
back it up to the icloud right of course
i say no
i've never plugged it in since you have
nothing backed up i said no there's
and i just have to deal with it every
time i just have a completely blank
slate
i lose everything all right yeah which
is you know unfortunate
um study found that people know between
1 000 and 10 000 faces of friends family
members colleagues and celebrities with
most racking up about 5 000. boom which
is
just above the population of antarctica
which means that you could potentially
know every last person on antarctica
yeah
that's what yeah that's amazing imagine
like you leave your house
and no matter who you see you know them
no matter where it's kind of fascinating
that is fascinating right
here we go four reasons planes don't fly
over antarctic can you can you
because because i'm telling you why they
don't fly over because if they fly over
they say weather conditions it's bs they
say lack of visibility it's bs
lack of infrastructure it's bs
navigation and other concerns kind of
okay because if you fly over that yeah
you will be shot down by the military
because they do not want you to see
whatever they're doing deep in
antarctica the only the people that have
the stations on antarctica go pull up a
map of antarctica
if you can pull up in order just pull up
a map of antarctica because i want to
show you i want to
show the viewers and delicious some of
you at home may be like i know this i
know what's going on some of you i don't
know
you see the little tip of an article all
the way at the top of that australia
yeah that's where all the bases are
that's where everything is the rest of
it which is bigger than
almost all the continents combined
nobody has ever seen they will not allow
anybody to fly over honourable snowman
just
walking around you're [ __ ] me i
promise you they think there's a whole
civilization
out there and they think that it's warm
what yes they think that
they the climate changes and it's warm
how do they think that not know it don't
we have all sorts of
sonar satellite capabilities can't we
tell by uh heat uh
i don't know i don't know
how many places of the earth do you
think are uh uncharted
i th well i think every piece of land
has been charted but the ocean
the oce we only know only no
five percent of the oceans 95
undiscovered wow
so so that mean they people think
there's over 1 billion
worth of treasure on the ocean floor
that we can never get to so if you you
could get more
you get it it's yours so there are
people because it's like international
water
international wars you get you go deep
sea dive right now that's why people do
it they really hunt for treasure
you go you go hunt for it's yours the
government can't take it away it's yours
you want it so if you're out there on
your ass you don't have a job
get in the oceans babe get in the air
you know what i mean like you're like
yourself an oxygen tank
you get yourself you know some goggles
get some deep sea diving get a
fisherman's boat
get out to the mariana trench take a
dive yeah you know maybe you don't you
won't have to live in your parents
basement
it's all singles that's the catch that's
the catch yeah
yeah so so you know the flat earth thing
i don't
do you think every single
land territory has been combed over i
uh like you just said antarctica they
like
well yeah pimp has now pulled up the 15
unexplored corners of the earth
so let's go okay number one valo
dejavari
javari brazil 14
uh amazon's uncontacted tribes most
isolated places in the world
wow 2 000 indigenous people live
autonomously from the brazilian
government in an area about the size of
austria wow austria by the way
shout out to austria i went there
briefly once i mean some of the best
chocolate
i've ever had in my life the view of the
mountains i was on a train
from uh uh germany to austria and the
fest was going i i i would say 40 pounds
and what time did you leave the station
i would say
i would i would i would say 50 miles per
hour i don't know what that is in
kilometers
because i know whatever it was it was in
kilometers how does a train derail
oh it's on track it's on track what's
going on there i know because they said
you're afraid of a train derailment does
that ever cross your mind no
when i see it i'm always shocked when it
should be because you're way more likely
to die in a derailment than a plane
crash
yeah right now yeah trains derail way
more than planes crash
okay right i thought you meant like if a
plane crashes the fatality rate
it's higher than anything because it
just every about every hour and a half a
train collides with another object or is
derailed
about every hour and a half every two
weeks the train that is carrying
hazardous material derails in the united
states
so this train's derailing every hour and
a half
we literally at the beginning this
episode a train derailed
yeah like hey train people yeah fix it
fix it what the hell i don't know you
don't have the technology to lock down a
train and
hey maybe tracks isn't the right answer
well no no because because because
you put anything on the track i mean an
animal could could do something on the
track
put a stick on the track and yeah but a
train what
yeah it's a track though but but you
can't guard the whole tracks
what are you going to put up walls or
the tracks people but people live on the
tracks you're telling me
that a train that is bolted to the
tracks that is scientifically engineered
to maintain a safe speed right it should
be
just be no risk involved on a train
right like it's all engineering
so if if a train is derailing it's it's
going too fast it shouldn't be allowed
to go that fast
now in incidences of accidents where
something goes out of control and the
train is speeding and they can't stop it
whatever like something from a movie i
get it
but every hour and a half a train is
colliding with something well because
here's the thing
i bet you that's uh that it's one of
those tips like where it's true
but it's not true because it's like yes
it probably derails every every hour and
a half
but there's probably some bs re there's
probably
to have a derailment is probably like a
loose thing like if it just like
hiccups a little bit they probably have
to report a derailment okay even though
nobody got hurt and they're still on
their way and the trap
i'm a full derailment when it goes off
the track that makes the news yeah like
unbreakable like i'm talking about
m shyamalan how great was that movie
unbreakable terrific
that was with denzel right tj miller
absolutely not you're thinking of the uh
outlander no the the i'm thinking of
yogi bear no you think you know
you're thinking of the guy that walks
into a room and he assesses everything
he's like the exterminator
is it unbreakable with denzel and tj
miller no unbreakable is what bruce
willis and samuel l jackson yeah
vehicle and split was the yeah by the
way split
can i just can i just take a moment
split and glass i like too can i just
take a moment and tell you right now i'm
going to look you in your eyes i'm going
to look the camera in the eyes i'm going
to look all the cameras in the eyes i
want to look everybody in the eyes and i
want to tell you right now i want to
make a claim and tell you
that in my lifetime i believe
unequivocally
that james mcavoy the lead of split is
the best actor
i've ever seen wow i'm going to say
james mcavoy
is my favorite actor and i think the far
and away
best actor on the planet right now that
includes being a better actor than kevin
costner
okay okay i have some people that i
think are the best actors
wait let me ask you james mcavoy isn't
it is that is that on the heels of the
movie split
or i couldn't believe how good he was in
split but what else do you love of him
i don't know any other movies he said
so split is the best movie you've ever
seen in your entire life i've ever seen
my life i was terrified from beginning
to end i couldn't believe
etc etc etc
yes dennis and all the characters i
couldn't believe what he did and then
when he became the beast
i couldn't believe how he made his body
like that and contorted that and it was
by far the best we've ever seen but now
that i'm talking out loud
i have never seen or heard of james
mcavoy
i i you know who i think is really good
who should be like a maybe he is a
household name and i don't know but i
know he's respected by his peers
michael shannon michael is sick
who's michael shannon he's in everything
and
oh i know michael shannon you know who
he is i think he gets yes he says i've
seen this guy he's getting started
allegedly he gets like wasted at a bar
in the lower east side
like weekly oh yeah i would yeah shannon
i don't know if he's from new york but
he's in new york a lot like he gets a
lit
allegedly like shit-faced all the time
just look at him he looks like
so distinguished yeah he was in a really
good movie i think the movie with jake
gyllenhaal
when he played like that cop
he was in um night creatures or
something like that he was like uh that
was another good night crawling
crawl was another girl yeah where's
shannon from no no no it was that movie
by tom
ford like midnight creatures ex like
something
like that yeah but like they they pull
them over
his cancer they kill like his wife and
his girlfriend
he's also funny do you ever see him in
the night before that seth rogen movie
no oh so funny no he's great and he's a
lawyer
oh he's the son of a lawyer i'm sorry um
august 7th in 1970
he's not he looks way older two years
older than me he looks
i incredible i thought he was in his 70s
he doesn't look incredible oh wait i
said he looks incredibly older than what
he actually is
my age no why are you born with a child
compared to him yeah can you pull
there's no way that that's right we're a
two-year difference
how was we made them look we've been in
school together
no he looks like a distinguished
gentleman and i look like a young kid
that's trying to get old
tell michael shannon we'd love to have
him on the pod michael if you're
listening
and we know that you know what you are
yeah please come on the pod we want to
come on the
absolutely oh how about this this is
real quick this happened did you see
this because we're talking about getting
eaten by a whale
did you see the story style this is a
real thing no but you know what our
podcast is like a train
the conversations get derailed the whole
time i love it but you know what you
know what
it makes it fun because what are you
supposed to do talk about one topic for
an hour
no this is this is the podcast for adhd
literally if you want us for an hour if
you want to go over legitimately
65 different topics this is the podcast
for you
and why not get your daily you're only
going to need to listen to this for a
week you go you got everything covered
yeah you got everything covered yeah you
could talk about 100 different things
i know you have a 100 conversation
starters after you come off of one of
our rantic
podcast rants if you still have social
anxiety at parties you have to listen to
this podcast with all the facts we're
giving you then it's really on you and
we'd advise you to go to
betterhealth.com
promo code hey baby and if you're hungry
magic spoon and if you need an erection
blue chill keeps and if you want to hide
your want to hide your internet
vpn express
um okay uh promo code hey babe and all
that so
if you're looking for nice clothes for
the summer macy's i took a big swing you
took a big
yes yes yes you can see what happens but
if and if macy's doesn't want to get in
then of course our friends at mac weldon
will have you covered
[Laughter]
um okay i mean again dude i know it's
just
every time we come in here we are rock
hard yeah i mean boner city yeah
it's it's like we every time we come in
we dock we're fine
yeah we're fine with people knowing yeah
and look now homeless pimps are taking
it look at how
hard homeless people are right i love it
that's got to be that's that's the
result of a blue chew is it not
because of course i said his table with
the computer and and
the sound board on i said it looks a
couple inches higher yeah i said what's
going on he said blue chill
yeah he's got a heart off blue cheese
guy blue chew is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and seattle's but
it's
chewable tablets and it's a fraction of
the cost the best part it's all done
online there's no doctor's visits
it's discreet there's no awkward
conversations you don't have to wait at
a pharmacy
i mean i mean the biggest one of the
biggest like
things that impedes getting the help you
need for any type of ed is you don't
want to go out there and blast it into
the streets
no it's very very very personal it's
annoying but bluetooth solves that
problem i was actually on a plane
coming over here yesterday and i kept
getting hit in the head and i was like i
turned around i said hey stop kicking my
cherry said oh it's blue chew yeah it's
it's not i said all right
i've been there i've done that you got
to you know congrats you got a stiffy
bluechew.com and you can have a stiffy
too here's how bluechu.com
promo code hey babe you get your first
month free so if you want a month
of free boners all you got to do is go
to bluetooth.com
put in the promo code hey babe it's safe
it's designed just for you i'm telling
you this little blue chew
will make you rock hard and you'll never
i mean your [ __ ] will be
it'll be painful but in a good one
you got to pay five bucks shipping
that's all they ask that's all they ask
thank you i couldn't see
that part over my boner blue chew get
you up and keeps you there
uh thank you for sponsoring the podcast
blue chew bluechew.com promo code hey
babe
dude did i ever tell you yeah did i ever
tell you about the time it was like a
period in my life where i was like you
know shaving my balls because the
girlfriend at the time said she didn't
like bush yeah so i was shaving my balls
and i cut one of my testicles clean off
yeah do you not remember you told me
this story hundreds of times
i'm begging you please stop telling me
the story cut it clean off i didn't go
to the hospital with my ball
in my hand yeah and i'm there with the
razor on my testicle on my hand and he
goes what the hell happened i said i cut
my balls off he goes you're not using
manscape yeah the doctor knew about it
yeah and i was like no and then he sewed
my balls up and when i woke up i had a
manscape 4.0 i the uh lawnmower 3.0
yeah on my channel no no no no no the
4.0 was that oh the four point i'm sorry
at the 4.0
which is um the lawnmower 4.0 which um
trims your balls so precise you will
never
cut your balls off using the lawnmower
4.0 like i did you look better when
you're manicured no
yeah you just look like you're putting
time and effort into the situation yes
right
yes absolutely i actually know freddy
had testicular cancer he got he wanted
go ahead no no no please tell him what's
his name in social he got
he got his ball he had to get a testicle
removed because obviously cancer thank
god he's okay he actually got his ball
re
he got put back in just so he could use
manscape and try the lawnmower 4.0
he told me i i wanted to get my you want
it back in because you need the weight
of the ball
to make the sack taut so you can go over
it with escape
otherwise it's just like an empty trash
bag exactly so we said now he's got two
balls and the only reason he did it so
he could use the lawnmower 4.0 buy
manscaped
that's it and you can use the lawnmower
4.0 by manscape too and we're going to
give you a nice deal if you go to
manscape.com
hey babe 20 off plus free shipping some
of these companies
[Laughter]
but they don't they're going to give you
free shipping 20 off manscape.com
so this guy this guy got
swallowed he says allegedly he was deep
sea diving looking for treasures and
lobsters
he off the coast of cape cod and
he caught cape cod
god gave cod that's that's how they
would say right cape cod
cape cod
he went out looking for treasures and
lobsters without telling us yeah he got
swallowed
got swallowed by a humpback whale yeah
gonna have a real cape cod funeral
cape cod and this is always the this has
always been the funniest name of the
town it's hyannis
but i just was like hi anus high honest
i don't know what it is
but but he was friday last friday
afternoon taken to cape cod hospital
because he claims he was swallowed whole
by a humpback whale and was inside the
whale's mouth
for minutes and then punched the whale
in the side of its body and
the whale spat him out and he broke his
arm
on the impact coming back into the ocean
no can't be true
it can't be true tell i'm telling you
this is what he's is this footage of it
no
no no there's no footage of it
miraculously and nobody believes
licensed commercial lobster divers pluck
lobsters off to sandy bottom and
uh uh um uh ocean where is it um
so that's what they do oh and then and
this guy's um
packard his last name was he says all of
a sudden i felt this huge shove and the
next thing i knew it was completely
black
packard recalled i could sense i was
moving and i could feel the whale
squeezing with the muscles in its mouth
he said packard thought he was inside a
great white shark
but he couldn't feel any teeth and he
had and he hadn't suffered any obvious
wounds it quickly dawned on him that
he'd been swallowed by a whale
i was completely inside it was
completely black i thought to myself
there's no way i'm getting out of here
i'm done i'm dead all i could think of
was my boys they're 12 and 15.
oh my god so that came out it was all
over the news but now fishermen have
come out and said that's just not true
it can't possibly be true
it can't but what do you think happened
what does he gain from this his name's
in the news
is he does he own a lobster business or
a lobster farm or something like that
if he doesn't maybe it's like he's
getting some eyes on his lobster
business name well they're saying
is it possible for a sperm whale to
swallow a human hole it is physically
possible
however such a person would be crushed
drowned or suffocated yeah that's what i
was thinking in the whale stomach
the muscles have to be so enormous that
it would crush you isn't this moby dick
yeah it's ridiculous yeah when i read
this i i couldn't stop thinking about
you sal
as a germaphobe what would you do how
would you handle that
yeah well first of all i don't know if
i'd be throwing haymakers inside the
whale i would just
i would probably just resign to the fact
that my
fists is not gonna save me when i'm
inside the bowels of the whale
you're saying if you were inside a wheel
you wouldn't fist it to try to get out i
i don't know what else are you gonna do
i'd be in there like you know what i
mean well what would you do take us
through
let's say you're swimming you're having
a good time you know maybe looking for
treasure maybe look for lobster maybe
you're just in the ocean having a good
time off the coast of cape cod
you get swallowed by a whale what do you
do you have your cell phone by the way i
want to let you know that you do have a
phone
okay just fyi okay and i just switched
to verizon recently so i probably have
service so especially especially off the
coast of massachusetts where verizon is
is very well
very predominant a lot of towers a lot
of towers if you had 18t t-mobile off
the coast no disrespect to them but i
think in the massachusetts area you want
verizon he's going to die in that whale
if you have t-mobile right but you have
verizon let's say you have one bar
honestly i would probably uh i would
probably
i don't know would i pray yeah i don't
really pray
you don't but i might i mean you're
looking for a last-ditch effort there i
might be like well if you're there if
you're there yeah yeah
please if you're listening i'll do it
from now on yeah yeah
i don't even understand yeah i like you
like what would you do what would you
what would you do
don't they say smoking crack or
something no um
okay hook so i would say
i would say if i was in there what i
would think to do
to try to like pull apart uh like like
stuff inside
something to to re i maybe try to start
to tickle yeah tickle it
something like that where it's like i
gotta get this thing out you know what
so
i started tickling the inside of the
whale as a child when we used to go
through the brooklyn battery my dad
would say we got swallowed by a whale
and we're in his stomach and we'd be
like this is insane
yeah and then like we'd be in it for a
while be like are we ever gonna get out
and he'd be like you gotta tickle the
roof
so it shoots us out so he would tell us
that when we got to the edge and then
we'd see the opening be like it's
hilarious
that's great that i'm gonna steal that
yeah um sperm whales
are so loud they could potentially
vibrate you to death
sperm whales are so loud that their
cliques are capable of killing a human
within their vicinity
wow says one science and adventure
journalist spermules are the loudest
mammals on the planet
uh they haven't i guess they haven't
tested uh my daughter
was vocalizations reaching an
astonishing 230 decibels i would like to
put my daughter up against the sperm
whale
and see who's louder sweet christ
okay so so yeah so so listen so tell us
what do you think do you think
do you think that do you think that he
um do you think that he really got
swallowed or no
is there a way that our fans can contact
the show yet
yeah they can send us an email where hey
babe pod at gmail.com
write to heybaypod gmail.com let us know
yeah
is it bs or was he really swallowed by
the way let me ask you this
can he get arrested for that false
narrative
where did they find him did he was
self-report to the hospital i think so
well no i don't think he could because
what did you really you had to go to the
hospital anyway you were injured
i know but if he called emergency
services on the heels of a fake
story and he employed like our attack
style like you can't just call the
police for no reason right you get in
trouble
you can't call the police and lie to him
right but let me ask you this
i can't call the police in line to them
but what if what turns out that i think
is an emergency is an emergency for
example
i actually got knock on my door once um
you know sick my daughter's six years
old i had called i didn't know that you
can't just
continuously call poison control so i
would call poison control and report
that my
i it did what my daughter just do is
that poisonous because i was so nervous
like i did it like 10 times and then
they alerted child protective services
and they knocked on the door
and they said hey we're here i swear to
god and they were like they talked to me
and jazz and delilah's mom and they were
like
what you know like we need to like give
a home inspection now because you've
called poison control ten times and we
were like we went to the impression
that that was there for us for our
comfort because she would take you know
so
you know that's how they answer the
phone poison control for your comfort
because i hate poison control another
one coming at you my daughter swallowed
a tide pod well yeah well
no because you know there was a couple
of times where she you know she
swallowed a magnet she swallowed like a
roach
in fact like things like that to like
war and poison control you can't keep
you can't you can't have eyes on it 24
7. yeah i i remember i remember one time
my daughter swallowed a magnet i was
drunk at the mets game with my friend
luca shout out lukash
and you know jasmine calls me and she's
like hey you got to get to the hospital
um right now delilah swallowed a magnet
and then i showed up to the hospital
drunk cause i was at the mets game i was
like oh she's with you know her mother
there's going to be no
problems and jasmine's yelling at me in
the emergency room she's like i can't
believe you're drunk right now your
daughter just swallowed a magnet i'm
like i don't know you're going to feed
her pieces of the refrigerator
like you know like i thought i thought
she's with her mom
that you know we're going to have mac
and cheese i like to flash back to you
at the game
but it's like two more beers you're like
i can't i can't just in case my daughter
swallows a magnet
yeah you never know it's i mean it's a
friday night she might my her mom my
feet are mementos from our trips to
aruba
so so so but but i called but you can't
call poison control because we would
call
kind of stupidly i remember and i would
and in fairness
jasmine really didn't do it that much it
was more me like i called once because
again just being so nervous
delilah she was maybe 18 months old and
i know this is stupid
but she got into a bag of chocolate that
was on the floor and she ate like six
chocolates i i you know she was like in
them you know she was just like just
getting teeth and
melting in her mouth and i saw like
wrappers and chocolate face and then i
immediately called because i thought
children were the ones who couldn't eat
chocolate but it's dogs
dogs but children can't eat poinsettias
right
yeah that's what it is but i can't so i
didn't know that
and i said i remember being on the phone
with poison control and being like she
ate so many chalks she was like okay
well is she having any stomach pains or
anything i said no like
what if it could be poisonous and they
were like no that's that's for dogs
and i remember like i remember there
being like a little bit of a beat and
being like
okay but then so i called portugal on
that but then i remember there was one
time where delilah sprayed febreze in
her mouth
and we kind of had a family decision
said there's no reason there's no reason
to call poison control but we should
have called poison because
we called on the chocolate so but anyway
after the tenth time
we got that knock on the door i was
shocked i thought i thought we're going
to lose our kid and they were like you
can't just
they were like oh like you know as a
matter of fact the play stroll guy was
maybe maybe after the 10th poison call
the it's you the problem it's yeah
that's what they were saying why is she
around so much poison
and in fairness i jasmine probably only
called once maybe
like poison control my daughter just
drank a bottle with a skull and
crossbones on it
we had them lying around yeah yeah no so
so
i kept calling and uh and but but they
told me there they're like you can't
just this isn't just like a
a line where you can just call like if
they really have to adjust
i didn't know them by me i thought it
was i was just hello boys in control
can i talk to sandra i usually deal with
sandra
i had one time i came home from being
out late
so i was like i had to be like two three
in the morning right right this is when
i lived in my little great socks
by the way from solid greens that's why
you got the thing right there
nothing says fourth of july like green
and white yeah happy fourth yeah i
celebrate my
independence vancouver grizzlies and
green socks that's how we roll we're
clashing right now but i like it
it's fine i could deal with it 3am i
come home by the way on july 4th real
quick because
obviously please not july 4th july 1st
barbecue at your place
yeah i'm gonna go oh barbecue if i don't
go somewhere okay
i was invited somewhere and i had to
figure it out if i don't
would love nothing more than to host
barbecue or place okay okay great pimp
you're in
if we have it okay um come home three in
the morning
i was out i walk into my apartment turn
on the lights close the door
come into the house drop my keys down i
go to like
wash my face brush my teeth down i'm
still fully dressed and
i'm in the bathroom and i hear what
sounds like
a police walking like a walkie-talkie
not a a walkie-talkie i heard like
okay i was like what the hell is that
right and i i
shut the bathroom light because it had
the fan right i shut it and i'm
listening
and there's someone right outside my
basement window and
right outside and there is a
walkie-talkie going off
and then i saw shadows and then i saw
them come down the steps
and i saw by the top of my door these
little windows at the top of the door
and i saw someone walk down then i heard
it right there i'm like
oh my god someone's about to break into
my house or something
right i was i was home less than three
minutes
coding and all that stuff is so hard and
we live in a digital world i didn't go
to school for coding i went to school
for physical therapy
and and my major in psychology i don't
know how to code anything but i want to
build a website for my business
squarespace.com far and away the best
place to do it they handle all the
coding stuff that you don't have to be a
freaking rocket scientist anymore to
make a website
you go to squarespace.com it's a dynamic
all-in-one platform where the customers
build a website claim a domain and sell
online and market a brand
squarespace.com wow that's all you need
to go i mean
that's i mean i don't even have anything
to add to this well the only thing i can
add to you for you is go to squarespace
squarespace.com
heybig for a free trial and when you're
ready when you're ready
to launch use the offer code hey babe
and you save 10 off your first purchase
of a website or domain
so squarespace.com hey babe when you're
ready to make the website you get 10 off
with the promo code hey babe
that's it what do you want me to do i
don't want you to do anything
you did everything just now i did
nothing i i think squarespace's numbers
are going to double a triple this week
i mean if they don't what are we doing
here we're in an age where everyone's
doing it themselves anyway remember when
you had to be like i wanna
i wanna make a website then you have to
like go pull like a number off a sheet
of paper on a telephone pole
because somebody could do html for you
not anymore not anymore squarespace.com
babe i love i'm loving my babble uh dude
i'm telling you i've noticed every time
i come in here it's like you're speaking
a different language me and pimp thought
you would go where i freaking getting
we thought you were possessed by satan
the other day i was speaking in tongues
you speaking 16th century tibetan
you learned it all on battle where else
you're gonna learn to babble is like a
fun language learning app that we keep
pushing but i'm telling you
it's one of those apps that i also go to
like i go to like my games yes or i go
to something to kill time
instead of going to social media why not
better yourself yes you spend an hour
scrolling looking at other
people's lives no you could spend 15
minutes on these
fun easy-to-go on-the-go lessons and
learn a language as you go in your spare
time
i mean come on they got 14 different
languages including
spanish french italian and german those
are the big ones so you go to babel
and here's what you do you go to baby
you learn the language and here's the
deal when you go to babel
because i'm just being blocked by the
camera hold on when you go to babel
there you go
babble.com that's b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
used to promo code hey babe that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com code hey babe
you get an extra three months free when
you buy three months so pretty much you
get six months
for the price price of three go to
babel.com and use the promo code hey
babe
b-a-b-b-e-l-dot code hey babe for an
extra three months free
every time i talk to someone they're
like oh i wish i could learn a second
language what are you gonna do you're
gonna sit in front of a computer all the
time
you're gonna go brick and mortar you're
gonna take a ride somewhere you're gonna
have to take a train to a bus
and go sit in a room with other people
that are probably sweaty and disgusting
no do it at the convenience of your own
time on your phone
on your app better yourself go as a
matter of fact do this i want our fans
right now go to babble.com put in the
promo code
hey babe for the three months free with
a purchase of three months
learn suck my ass rosetta stone in
whatever language you choose
tweet it hey babe pod on twitter yes
please
right right oh son i hear boom boom boom
i go hello
they go open it i [ __ ] you not open the
door
police wow i swear to god i'm like
there's no way this is the police right
so i'm like this person's gonna
i'm not opening the door they're gonna
kick my door open come in and sold me
and steal something
they probably saw me come in and they
tailed me this is i mean
wouldn't that be what you think of
course so i go
i'm not opening the door they're like
you have to open the door it's the
police
i said i'm not open the door and then i
heard their walkie-talkie and it was
like police chatter on it
right so i was like how do i know you're
the police and they're like we're the
police
and there was like multiple people it
was like three guys
yeah so i opened the door it's the
police
right and they go you just called and i
go called
and they're like yeah you just called us
there's a problem did i tell you the
story no this has happened to me
does this happen to you yep okay i don't
know if i ever told this story no no no
this just never happened to me this is
fascinating so i go i i go i definitely
didn't just call they're like all right
you want to tell us why you called they
like didn't believe me they were giving
me [ __ ]
and i was like i i i said not only did i
not call i go i've been home
three minutes right i go i just walked
in i go i walked in the door i went to
go wash my face
yeah i was like and then i heard your
your walkie-talkies and
they go you called why did you call and
i'm not
gonna be like why are you wash your face
immediately and i go i go
i go i go this is like freaking me out
and they go look at me i go okay if i
called i go wouldn't i
wouldn't i have the number in my phone
my landline
right wouldn't i have the number and she
goes hold on they get on the phone with
the with the
operator they say dial back the number
that just called and my
phone rings my landline rings and i
i i the the feeling that went through my
body and then
they looked at me like see you called
and they still think i'm like for some
reason
skirting something or lying to them and
i just was like in shock
and i'm like i have no reason to call
you nothing's wrong
i just got home i said i don't
understand why my phone is ringing i'm
like
did someone call from my is someone in
the closet
yeah right so they're just like all
right well you can't call like that
anymore and they go to walk away go wait
i didn't call like you can't leave right
now like i'm freaking out like
you don't yes you don't want to
investigate further i'm telling you the
truth why my phone just rang
and they're like no well and they just
left and then and then i was home that
night
and and i looked and i don't know to
this did you have a landlord was this
one you were living was this your own
private restaurant
landlord upstairs but it was three in
the morning and also my landline is my
own it's not his
it's not connected to his so to this day
no
idea now did your friends have a key
because that's a good prank
no no no one no one did that
no one did that well what happened to
you because because
is it is this the common thing mine
isn't as i wanted
i said how are you guys walking away
knowing that i swear to you like right
now i have no reason to lie anymore
so you guys aren't you don't want to
investigate and then
they were over it they didn't care at
all that's creepy that's weird when
when the phone rings like on the wall
i know yeah i know and i i i just it's
one of those things
now that we're thinking about it like
could it have been just a dial a
switchboard
i mean is that a thing like is that just
a fake word lines get crossed
my question is did somebody die because
of you now
right because of you because of the
switchboard problem where
the person who needed the 911 call they
were off by one digit
and now something terrible happened to
them and you've gone on to fame and
fortune
what a twist of fate twist of fate this
is weird oh it happens all the time
supposed 9-1-1 call from my phone that i
didn't make
alerted my dad and changed my emergency
preferences
okay what so my dad called me in a panic
at 10 a.m that says this morning
saying he received a notification that i
called 9-1-1 i was in the shower
no one had access to my phone and
there's no trace of it in my call log
verizon turned off my emergency phone
call access as a result
which my dad had to turn back on friday
the 13th
thing or glitch in the system what was
it friday the 13th
if that happened on friday 13th was it
friday the 13th
that's it that's it then it had to be
friday you mentioned it now that you
mention it
by the way i just because i'm a little
freaked out yeah
someone in your house you know someone
in the in the studio
thing just walked down and i literally
almost [ __ ] my pants
because i've never in 25 episodes doing
the show seen anyone up here
and i literally because i was already
freaked out by the 911 i looked over at
that time
and saw that person and genuinely my
heart is in my throat right now
my heart i have a 150 heart rate right
now
walking into that room too hey babe i
walked
into that room too and at the in the
corner of my eye i just was like that's
definitely just a ghost
i couldn't believe i was like oh my god
this is the 9-1-1
that would say about the time uh my cell
phone rang i picked it up and it was a
woman screaming at me
did i j i swear to god she i might
what's her name jasmine
this was the flip phone days yeah flip
phone but color
pictures okay that era like when they
had the little colors
i'm gonna say 2008. say it yeah right
and
hello and she goes who the do you think
you are how dare you and i
she just screams screams you're like
hello yeah and she's like
whoa who is this and i was like i'm so
sorry who is this she goes
you just texted me a dick pic
i swear to god oh my god you just texted
me i said
you just write my phone i've never seen
this number in my life
i said you need to calm down like i i
said i have no reason to lie to you you
don't know me
i said if i did i could like just hang
up on you i didn't do it
wow she goes yes you did i go ma'am i
swear to you i'm sorry you got this and
i don't know how you got it right i was
like but i would never do that nor did i
i don't know you i don't know this
number
oh my god she's like oh i i i don't know
if i believe you i go
well i go i i'm telling you you should
have sent her a picture of your dick i
feel like you see
well how about this i go i swear to god
she goes i she goes
she goes yes you i go i would i go i
swear to god i go send me this photo
send me the photo text
it to me text me she texts it to me i
said ma'am do you still have it
ah you got everybody's number for 98 but
you don't have the random dick pic i
could have put it on the page
i will tell you this i still have the
phone if i can charge it and find it i
might have it
if you could charge it and find it i
mean it's at the definition of patreon
you got to keep the list by the way the
patreon i know that we will be silly it
is
not a joke it's not a joke and it is
genuinely comfortable i know some people
like at this point i don't know if it's
a joke
the reason we can't do the patreon right
this second is because we're so
uh consumed with getting you the
episodes because chris has been in l.a
the second he comes back from l.a in a
couple of weeks we're starting
the patreon by the way reason i've been
in l.a coming up next week july
4th july 8th 10 30 p.m backyard bar wars
after a brand new episode of impractical
jokers at 10 p.m
so we got 10 p.m in prague's joker's 10
30 mining show backyard borrowers i mean
if you're a babe
you got you know what you know what
you're doing thursday nights now 10 to
11 you're booked
because once it airs we're going to
start talking about it and you guys are
going to want to know what we're doing
it's going to be overload it's going to
be
we come out we come out at 11 a.m on
thursdays and then 11 and then and then
you have your day set so your whole day
is
thursdays for the next 10 weeks yeah
yeah yeah
that's what it is yeah so patreon if i
can find it we'll have this picture
she texts me it i and and and uh what's
weird is she was on the phone
so i guess you could text it while
you're on the phone cause i looked at it
and i
was like ma'am i am a white man it was a
black penis
i was like i did not call you i swear to
god i gotta be honest she was like all
right all right
but to be fair i'm white i wouldn't say
my penis is white
would you say your penis is white yeah i
guess i don't have a black penis but i
don't have a white penis sometimes that
region
like it adopts like a bit of a different
different color it's different hue
it's not black i don't know it's not a
size yeah that's not a
i would i would say if i would say i
have white skin and my penis is middle
eastern
right that's what i would say it's right
it was the color jesus most likely was
like bronze yes yeah yes you know i have
a middle eastern
shaded penis yeah shut up middle east
shout out middle east shout out shade i
hope
you know peace hopefully peace comes you
know yeah israel palestine figure it out
yeah i
we just wish for the best for everybody
yeah uh americans consume around 150
million hot dogs on the fourth of july
each year 150 million hot dogs how do
you think about that
oh it's the 4th of july it's the 4th of
july yeah we talk oh that means the
the the hot dog eating competition is
going to come back on i mean
is that the best company because it was
cancelled last year it has to be no
it was indoors behind plexiglass last
year i watched it
i spoke to you about it because it was
insane because there's like six men and
six women yeah
chestnuts kobayashi shout out
by the way real quick i met joey
chestnut once and i i i know i coulda
caught you on a bad day in buffalo i was
doing helium buffalo
i said hey what's up i'm a big fan and
you looked at me and said nothing just
just want to let you know what's up with
that show i remember that joe and
i'm still a fan you are still hoping and
praying that you win on
on on the july 4th hot door getting
contest but it was a little like you
know i was really excited to see you and
you didn't give me the time of day
granted we were in buffalo and it's
depressing there
but you know but actually you know
whatever but though i mean you're if
you're recognizing joey chestnut you
just hope he at least gives you a nod
back
i was still wearing my poncho from the
niagara falls ride and i was just really
excited to see you and uh you didn't
give me the time of day yeah
is it something that you go through
every day joey chestnut yeah you walk
around like jesus i'll get bombarded
yeah the life of joey chestnut you just
don't know what it is yeah i just you
know i
just wanted to say you know joey i think
um i think kobayashi would have been a
little nicer
he probably would have yeah it's a rough
lifestyle those guys have day jobs
yeah dude no joey chestnut can't have a
day job google joey chestnut's net worth
he has to be sponsored by somebody now
at this point right
73 dogs why is joey chestnut never been
in the nathan's commercial how much is
he worth
1.5 million not that that's bad but i
was expecting
i was expecting way more yeah because
also what kind of i mean what kind of
sponsorship should he has
outside of nathan's i would throw him i
mean nathan should have thrown him big
money though no
i know you know he walks away from that
competition he's got nathan by the dogs
he does he should maybe he should flex a
little like he does with you
yeah maybe he should treat nathan's like
the stephanie yeah because it was a
little bit
like hey joey coming at the fourth july
party he's just like i don't know if i
can know you i don't know who the hell
you are
yeah well i got news for you joey
chestnut guess who knows guess who
the new faces subreddit is right here oh
so
michael jordan used to endorse shabbat
really wasn't michael jordan the sabret
guy
i don't know google michael jordan's
sabrette what did you say
he put soprano spokesperson no sabret
s-a-b-r-e-t-t there's a brett michael
jordan google's
brett jordan i'm i'm pretty sure jordan
was sabrette
they had some money there you go he's
there jordan money there he is mike
here's the michael jordan commercial
lake hodson
can we show this commercial is it just
for us
think about what this man had to do
he wasn't even there he's in front of a
green screen and all he's doing is going
yeah not yet not yet by the way it
wasn't spread it was ball park franks
and it came up when you googled the red
yeah it was ballpark frank's
maybe when he switched over to the white
sox i'm like how does he have his hand
in everything well no it's 98 that he
won the championship though yeah you
know okay
wow so that one ballpark put up money
for that big
i mean you don't picture like michael
jordan the greatest contempo
athlete at the time to be like hot dogs
yeah you know yeah but i mean hey they
probably gave them five
million yeah some bread hot dogs
recalled over pieces of bone
because do you know what a hot dog is um
entrails right not want to know what
just like it's just like everything
it's fourth of july we're all about
knowing what's put in your body what is
a hot dog a lot of nitrates
big nitrates but it's pork and beef um
uh
what are hot dogs made of here we go
made from the meat trimmings which are
grounded to a fine mixture with other
ingredients added for flavor the mixture
is poured into a casing to create the
shape hot dogs are a cheap source
of protein no no what actually what
animals
what animal there we go beef veal pork
um i thought it was sheep casing i
thought it was sheep intestine
was what the casing of it was what makes
a hot dog gross 17 hot dog ingredients
that make it okay
here we go chicken trimmings trimmings
when you say the word trimmings that's a
red flag right there i don't want to eat
a trimming
trimmings is like what you cut off the
meat
yeah right it's like i mean that's
disgusting dude i don't want to eat a
trimming
um antibiotics okay hey listen if you
don't
have a cold even have a cold yeah got
strep variety meats which is never good
livers kidneys and hearts of various
animals okay it's a little barbaric
beef fine natural sheep casing that's
what gets
there you go what about when they see it
all be frank then you they're not
telling you we don't have
all the trimmings unless they can well
what did you consider sheep beef or
poultry
i don't know have you ever eaten a sheep
no dude i only mean feta cheese lamb
isn't a gyro right sheep
we don't eat sheep right what's it
between a sheep and a lamb no clue
no nor a goat what's between a sheep a
lamb and a goat
not a clue they're between a sheep and a
lamb who says bad
sheep is a woolly ruminant mammal that
is related to the goat
lamb is a young sheep that is under one
wow so when you're eating lamb you're
eating
you're eating lamb baby sheep ah that's
disgusting
if you've ever eaten a lamb gyro you're
a pedophile lamb
where's the lamb of god we take away the
sins of the world what does that mean
really god you're going to the lamb of
god so now you got to kill a baby sheep
is that a sacrifice yeah but for
sacrificing a one-year-old sheep
to take away yeah
you're gonna put that on me i stole a
pack of gum from 7-eleven when i was
four you're gonna kill a lambo i gotta
kill this baby lamb what the hell is he
doing
oh she did you or the lamb was a baby
sheep i had no idea so lamb
when you're eating lamb so what's a
ghost i've never had lamb in my
goat like a never once had lamb yeah i
don't think i have
never had lamb and i actually now that i
know this i never will
yeah i never ever well jamie is it gamey
i don't even want to know but i would
never in a million years
a veal is a baby cow right yeah
yeah so goats are browsers they look for
leaves
by the way they're not shaming i don't
want to sheepshame people that eat lambs
you eat lamb you can still listen to the
podcast no problem it's just not for me
yeah lamb it up
it's not for me yeah what's up it's not
for me either go ahead the only
difference between the two is how they
forage
that's the main difference it's foraging
between a sheep and a goat is just how
they
what is a goat i think a goat is it in
the sheep
family ghosts
a ram i think is a not like a dodge ram
like a goat ram a dot of a ram
goats ram each other with the they well
a ram it's got maybe it's a male
goat so the la rams are they goats
they might be ghosts no a ram is a ram a
ram is heavier and larger compared to
goats
horns are longer and curved over the
back uh uh
the head of the rams while those more
erected and less curved than a goat goat
has many okay so a ram and a goat are
different so there's female rams i
always thought a ram was the male
version of a goat i thought
is a male sheep and there's a different
so the ram is the male
so a lamb can become a ram yeah so when
we're eating
we're in goats it's all women i mean the
feminism movement needs to talk about
that
we're only eating female animals and
goats
cows are women because the male is a
bull all cows are women wow
wow every cow every time you eat a
burger you're eating a
woman is that right yes what about a
bison
i think bisons only have one sex i think
it's just male 1 i don't know about that
sounds ward that sounds weird yeah it's
probably not right oh interesting
in traditional agriculture you tend to
eat more males than females
the females are kept for breeding and
the excess males are eaten since you
only need a few to inseminate lots of
females but i thought cows
that's for agriculture so it's the
opposite and then
i think for meat we eat the females
right
can you tell me what a ram is though i
mean i'm sorry a goat a goat
so a lamb is a sheep and a ram is a
sheep but a goat
is what is it just a goat who's he
related to
go ahead while sheep and goats seem
similar and can be mated
wow they belong to different
genera genera in the
subfamily kapernae of the family bovidae
there you go
all right a lot of words there sheep
belong to the genus ovis
and the 54 chromosomes while goats
belong to the genus copra
and have 60 chromosomes so they're kind
of like the same but what happens
when you when a sheep and a goat mate
they're closely related
but they're in different sub-families
they call it if they do mate it's called
a hybrid and it's called an
[Music]
u-e-w-e
wait a buck is a male goat so a ram is a
male sheep
okay a buck i thought buck hunting oh
buck hunting
male goats you have the video game i do
but i don't see male goats running
around on that
do i fascinating stuff
we have to figure this out literally i'm
not setting off fireworks to commemorate
america's birthday until we figure this
out
we need to figure this out wow oh my god
dude dude before because we wrote this
down i need to
i did yes stand up
yes for steve cohen the owner of the
mets
sal i bombed
and you cannot believe that this has
been abandoned thank you so much
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe
hey babe hey babe hey babe
hey